Hello, my name is Steve Sterns and I'd
like to welcome you into this course on
evolutionary medicine.
It is aimed at audiences
that include undergraduates,
medical students and uh,
physicians who are interested in CME
credits and anyone else who was interested
in evolutionary insights
in the medical issues.
Yeah,
the course is supported by a book which
just was published a few days ago.
Uh,
it's coauthored with Russell on med
cutoff and it's available from sign our
associates.
The scope of the book actually
defines the scope of the course.
Evolutionary insights are more important
in some parts of medicine and the R and
others.
And we concentrate on issues where
evolutionary biology and evolutionary
thinking brings insights that can
reduce suffering and save lives either
immediately or as basic
research continues.
So she insights are distributed across
many different parts of medicine for like
physics and chemistry.
Evolutionary biology is a basic science
that underpins all of medical science.
Okay,
here's an overview of the topics.
In chapter one we introduced evolutionary
thinking and then we ask to rather
interesting questions.
What does a patient and what is a
disease that issue what is a disease,
sets up the discussion of defenses and
then takes us on into pathogen evolution,
discussion of cancer, reproductive
medicine and the issue of mismatch.
We then go on into mental disorders,
discuss how individual versus
population thinking, uh,
is involved in health. And the
book concludes with open questions.
Yeah.
So in this introduction to
the course and this welcome,
I just want to very quickly take you
through the highlights of those chapters.
So in evolutionary thinking,
uh,
we recognize the biological evolution
is both a process called micro evolution
that produces a pattern
called macro evolution.
And both of these ways of
thinking are relevant to medicine.
The toolkit of these ideas for
microevolution includes natural selection,
random processes,
genetic drift,
genetic change and development.
In macro evolution,
the framework shifts to history,
how history defines relationships,
provides an origin for
constraints and again,
insights into development.
What do we think about what is a patient?
I think the first thing we recognize is
that patients are bundles of trade offs.
They are not built like machines
with parts that you can just replace.
They contain ancient
patients vary for both senate and
genetic and environmental reasons.
They age,
which makes them vulnerable and
they are unusual among primates.
They also contain very
important microbiota which
are playing an increasing role
in medical explanation.
When we come to what is the disease?
I think the first thing to mention is
that instead of using the traditional
categories of infectious versus chronic,
we placed diseases into seven categories
that reflect their causes and which
relate to whether they, whether evolution
could have affected the fences are not
the tissues in the organism and the
patient very from vulnerable to robust.
The physiological functions that are
involved in disease very from fixed to
adjustable and many diseases are produced
by interactions between genes and
environment.
So those are some of the highlights about
disease that sets up the discussion of
defenses.
Defense mechanisms have usually evolved
as modifications of processes that were
already part of normal
physiology evolution.
We'll tolerate high costs and will permit
significant vulnerabilities when those
costs and those vulnerabilities
are associated with major benefits.
Some defenses have major benefits and
are associated with large costs and
significant vulnerabilities.
Yeah.
Pathogens evolve and they
evolve quite rapidly.
They have their own agendas and
they respond to human interventions.
The responses include virulence,
their roles in the Microbiota,
the evasion and suppression of defenses,
resistance to antibiotics and reactions
to attempts to prevent their own
evolution,
so they are a flexible and
highly adjustable population.
Okay.
Cancer is a very interesting
part of evolutionary medicine,
both because there is a historical
component evolution build vulnerability to
cancer deep into the design of our bodies,
it's going to be almost impossible to
change that design and eliminate that
vulnerability.
Every cancer is an independent instance
of clonal evolution and that is fueled
by genetic variation.
That evolution creates a
unique evolutionary history
with each patient and that
evolution can be reconstructed with
molecular phylogenetic so that we can
actually see the history of
an individual cancer. Okay.
That every cancer evolves has some very
important implications for therapy.
Yeah.
There are also evolutionary insights that
are quite interesting and important in
reproductive medicine.
Evolution helps us to understand
ministration menopause,
the difficulty of childbirth
and the diseases of pregnancy.
Okay.
It also allows us to see
that the evolution of the
placenta is connected to the
risk of cancer. Evolutionary
conflicts over parental investment.
Help us to understand the diseases of
pregnancy, gestation length, birth way,
and give us some insight
into middle of disorders.
Reproductive events
that occur early in life
have consequences for health late in life.
So there was a whole complex
of interesting issues
built around the process of
reproduction.
Okay.
Mismatch is one of the major concepts
in evolutionary medicine and it arises
because our environment has recently been
changing more rapidly than our biology
can keep up with.
Yeah.
The resulting mismatch between
biology and environment producers,
mild to severe loss of evolutionary
fitness, which is expressed.
His contributions to disease states.
These diseases include obesity, type
two diabetes and cardiovascular disease,
female reproductive cancers,
asthma and autoimmune diseases.
So these are part of the complex of
diseases that are part of the worlds
emerging huge health burden.
Okay.
There are also evolutionary
insights into mental disorders.
Probably the most important one is that
mental disorders are disturbances of
cognition and behavior that function
well in most, but break down in a few.
Yeah.
Cognition and behavior are
complex processes that are
influenced both by genetic
and by developmental events. They have
many components, each of which can vary.
That variation produces a distribution
of cognition and behavior.
Yeah.
We can view some mental
disorders as byproducts of
selection for normal behavior
caused by inescapable
features of complex systems,
so you can think of the normal behaviors
being the center of the distribution
and the mental disorders as being
the tails of the distribution.
They can also be disorders of defense,
of homeostasis and of mismatch.
So there are a number of
different evolutionary
insights into mental disorders.
Yeah.
In chapter 10 we discuss individual
health versus population benefit.
There are conflicts that arise
between individuals and populations.
When physicians treat their decisions
accumulate to have consequences for
epidemiology, demography,
and even natural selection.
Those consequences often contain conflicts
between the welfare of the individual
and the welfare of the group involving
externalization of private costs and
exploitation of public goods.
Important examples include
vaccination and antibiotic therapy,
and this is the point at which morality
enters the discussion of and how it is
connected to evolutionary insights.
Finally,
we close the book with some of the
open questions because naturally any
searching analysis reveals many
places where we need to know more.
Can we design evolution
proof antibiotic therapies?
Can we switch the host pathogen
relationship from resistance to tolerance?
Do Pathogens evolve greater virulence
when leaky vaccines are used?
Does adaptive therapy
slowdown cancer revolution?
Do Evolutionary Tradeoffs
suggest treatments for aging?
And does genomic imprinting help to
explain autism and schizophrenia?
There were some indications that it helps.
So in conclusion,
evolutionary thinking,
cast new lights on many areas of
medical research and practice,
it complements other approaches.
It does not replace them.
It helps to reduce
suffering and save lives,
but it also contains fascinating ideas.
It's fun.